so I had a tweet I said no 35 year old
women aren't that hot none will compete
with the average in-shaped 21 year old
don't shoot the messenger now the reason
I had this thought was because I would
see top 35 year old women that were just
really really attractive right the
models the whatever and I would think to
myself on an average college campus you
could probably find like 10 chicks that
are equally as good looking as them if
not more now it's not to say that
there's no women that are attractive at
35 or pretty but we live in this
delusion where we tell women they're
going to be hot forever and at 35 most
women would aim to have a family and
kids and really have more of an identity
in their character over their looks yeah
but every time I I make a broad
generalized statement where I know
there's exceptions but we we're talking
about the rule right everyone gets mad
and the wives just start arguing with me
about their hotness yeah yeah yeah yeah
and so Ashley Sinclair
um says Pearl has started adding the
qualifier in shape now because it's not
that 22 year old is hotter than 32 it's
just by 33 many women get fat and let
themselves go at 22 it's less likely
that was my argument months ago seems I
convinced her now I'd like to say to
this Ashley chick no you did not
convince me I would say that if you have
a 22 year old chick that is not fat in
general they're hotter than a 32 year
old chick and that same chick is in
general going to be hotter at 22 than 32
and I think you see this in the modeling
industry where women age out pretty
quickly you said you worked with models
in New York yeah I work with fashion
models in New York City for about 10
years okay and I would bring them out to
the nightclub and I would charge a fee
and I remember that a lot of the models
that come in at 17 18 Full of Life full
of energy full of optimism
then maybe about three four years later
if they're still even in New York
they're beaten down they're destroyed
you know um age is undefeated again and
you're constantly competing with women
that are 17 18 19.
um and back then you know fashion models
was much more prestigious than
you know the weird stuff you see in
2020. it was yeah yeah like the New York
Fashion Week yeah Paris Fashion Week it
wasn't that it was even back then it was
sort of like odd but now it's just
become next year of odd yeah back then
it was actually prestigious to work with
fashion models yeah
um
but the idea that women they fall off
because you're constantly competing with
you know young women and my thought is
when I said that hot
that to me when you say you're that hot
by 35 you should be beautiful because
your character in my opinion your
character should be developed to the
point where you're beautiful you're not
hot anymore you're a wife you're a
mother yeah but it's like how hot do you
want to be as a mom don't you want to be
beautiful you know yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and so when I said that hot I'm
like it's not like top 10 of beauty I
look at Margot Robbie right she she was
a smoke show God in Wolf of Wall Street
all the men loved her now you know and
it's interesting you see this happen to
the women when they're younger they're
in the they're in the movies that market
to men so Wolf of Wall Street Megan Fox
Transformers they get older they start
being cast in Wim and movies that are
for women
wow you notice that so like Margot
Robbie Barbie that's like women watch
that wow and I think it's because women
don't like to see women that hot on TV
wow but men do so like in the Man movies
you'll see like the hottest I mean all
the hottest chicks are in the in the Man
movies you know yeah yeah yeah
um okay so I responded to this chick
because
I said no by 33 you're less hot than 23.
the only exception is if you were obese
you know because I was like all right if
the 23 year old was fat that's not
really the same territory but you get
less hot as you get older by 35 most
chicks Have Wrinkles sag a bit and have
under other indicators of Aging do not
shoot the messenger is this untrue
I think you nailed it I think she hates
you because you nailed it
it's like it's okay if it's I didn't say
you're a bad person so I I have this um
thing where I talk about simping yeah
and I I think that simps are equally as
bad as the modern women yeah because
they allow us to live in delusion and a
lot of times what I notice is when men
process information their first reaction
in general is if it's true yeah unless
they're simple yeah then because women
process information like individually so
they'll say like how does this apply to
me like if I say nope a 22 year old is
hotter than a 32 year old you know
they'll say well but I they're like
their reaction as well but I was but I'm
hotter now than I was at 22 do you know
which it's usually cope but you know
what I'm saying so where men will will
think more in general yeah except for
The Sims so now doctor interracial says
my wife is 63 and hotter than Pearl
and it's funny because I was never
talking about his wife I was never
talking about my looks
yet they feel the need to insult me or
you know by tweeting me pictures of his
wife like well this is weird this is
weird Behavior yeah
the idea that you're going to use your
wife
an image of your wife and then attack
someone's daughter
that's just a poor away poor taste of
showing his point like I understand he's
simping for his wife
but he's also
degrading another man's daughter so I
don't really look at him as a guy of
high moral Authority like he could have
proved his point without because at the
end of the day you're actually another
man's daughter
I have a daughter as a man you'll never
know what that feels like bro you know
what I mean yeah so the fact that he
degraded you to make an example is
disgusting who does he think he is he's
not he's no moral Authority this is he
probably votes for Kamala you know what
I'm saying right actually I think he's a
conservative but yeah I don't understand
probably a closet liberal I don't know
but that's the thing it's like you know
I it's like the guys like this that
co-sign us and make us think we're like
hot for a lifetime and it's just not
true again when you get older you should
you should be beautiful your goal should
it be to be like a sex object it should
be to be beautiful for your family and
your husband you know because there's
something about like even if it's like
an older woman that is just like really
happy with her family and her children
and you you know you know what I mean
yeah where like I don't know who comes
to your head but there's like a couple
women that come to mind where okay
they're a bit older but it's like seeing
them interact with their husband and
their family they're just beautiful
they're not sexy they're not hot they're
they're Grandma they're mom but they're
it's beautiful because they're not
trying to be a sex object anymore yeah
yeah and like and hot to me when you say
hot that that implies more of like a sex
object beautiful is like something
that's more intangible you know yeah now
facts simply aren't facts Pearl so these
women they start tweeting them either
selfies
I think I think I think it's looking at
the Tweet is crazy
I mean it's it's yeah so that was her I
guess younger on the left and on the
right and so I just you know there
there's her
she looks like a nice girl yeah that's
her daughter
no I mean that's like that's her at 32 I
guess and that was her at 22 so 22 and
then 20 years later so and then but like
what's the point of like doing this body
comparison
like does that take away from your main
point that you may like you still made a
good valid point like what what has this
become like a competition or focusing on
each other's looks it's distracting from
the main topic well so yeah and I
responded and I'm like all you did was
get more naked
I'm like you just like took off your
clothes
but I've just noticed whenever I tweet
anything about younger being hotter it's
like women were so used to be like think
look at marketing like you just notice
all the movies are casting older women
all the models are getting older it's
just like pantering yeah it is it's not
what men any if you want to look at like
what men like look at the male movies
and look at who's cast like wasn't
Avengers it was Scarlett Johansson yeah
yeah
I mean I've I've seen I've seen I've
been you know I've been like right with
Scarlett Johansson in a New York City
Deli oh really and Tribeca we live in
the same neighborhood and she's actually
like a very petite small
girl yeah and like very small petite and
very quiet
so when I see her in the superhero
movies I'm I'm sort of like it's so far
from what's wrong actually like yeah
it's beyond beyond far from what reality
is like
um so I want to give you like my take on
marriage in 2023 okay I want to give you
my take so and then you give me your
take too yeah I think marriage
traditional marriage is beautiful I love
seeing couples that like make that work
I think it is amazing
um but what I what I don't want is men
not making an informed decision
so I think that men should be aware of
the risks that come with it so that's
kind of my opinion and I I think that
some men and this is regardless of what
I say or I don't say you're with the
laws being how they are you're going to
keep seeing men walk away from Marriage
until the laws change it's going to be a
bigger and bigger number every year
regardless of what Pearl says because
again men are kind of logical right so
they kind of weigh the risks of marriage
and the rewards and you know sometimes
they'll meet a girl where the reward is
worth it right and they'll say you know
what I know this system's against me
some guys go to different countries to
figure this out like it just depends on
the guy
um but until we start lowering the risks
the women of 2023 are definitely worse
than the women 20 years ago those women
are worse than the we're just seeing a
trend across the board I don't say this
in a happy way I'm not happy about it
but it's becoming more and more
difficult for men to be traditional
because many men are punished for being
traditional yeah and
um what I see a lot of times is the men
that say you know what this is too much
I don't want to do it they're shamed by
the traditional conservatives for making
that choice
and I think for men sometimes
and and I think it depends on the guy
right so you know I think a YouTuber is
gonna have a very different experience
than say a factory worker yeah and you
know we need Factory workers for this
country to run we need truckers we need
plumbers and I think they just sometimes
have a hard time and a lot of times
those are the guys we see like walk away
does that make sense yeah yeah because
you know again with the Instagram
economy it's really hard to have the
average woman stay unless you're
exceptional as a man yeah unfortunately
I don't say this in like a happy way so
cernovich says ninety percent of men
speaking out against marriage aren't
sought after the truth is that a desired
man who isn't a sociopath will date
widely enough until he meets someone who
has his number and that's it the Playboy
or whatever is a goober myth from a beer
commercial so
um I wanted to talk about the first part
in my experience this is just from like
interviewing guys getting screwed in
divorce I I think a lot of the guys that
speak out against marriage actually had
success in dating and got married and
then just got screwed over yeah yeah I I
think I I'm a big fan of Mike I think
he's a great guy he's a great family guy
I agree with him in regards to 90
percent of men who speak out again
ninety percent of men speaking out
against marriage aren't sought after
okay
I mean if I couldn't get any [__] and
I had six inches taken off my dick
I would probably have the same Theory
yeah see I disagree
no no no that's it it's just it's just I
think that I think that there are a lot
of attractive men yeah that are actually
able
I don't want to use the word dominate to
disrespect all the the loving and
respectful wives out there but they are
the dominant force in the family as the
clear Undisputed leader like to the
point where you can have a woman say
yeah you are the man and you are the
leader not that doesn't mean she's the
donkey or the cow in the relationship
you still love your wife you treat her
good but I do think that there are a
group of men who are good ladies men
yeah these are the sort of men that are
ladies men these are the sort of men
that are good with women and they get a
wife that is actually
and I don't want to use the word
subservient but
they are very respectful and they admire
their husband
are there a lot of guys that are Simpson
get walked over we both know to answer
that well I think I think you're just
like do you think 60 of men aren't not
good enough for marriage because 60 of
men aren't looking for marriage and
relationships put it like this girl so
so like in my head it's like the average
man used to be able to get an average
woman you know he didn't have to be this
like six foot tall he didn't have to be
have this amazing job in order to
attract a woman it was like an average
guy I could get 120 pound virgin
in my in Mike's defense yeah let's just
say for example my care Mike is like six
foot four athletic build successful
highly intelligent his wife I can I've
never met his wife but I from what I see
his wife respects him so he might have
not the same but that doesn't mean every
guy can do what he did well that's
that's my point is a lot of times the
guys that come at this are kind of like
you know rich men tend to stay married
longer right they they tend to their the
divorce rate's like 25 among like rich
men I don't know that yeah so I think
they live in a different reality than
the average men in this country so I'll
give you an example one of the top in
the Merrick anyone one of the top places
people are employed is Truckers
okay yeah so and the average man makes
forty five thousand dollars a year I
don't think those men are losers I think
I think a lot of times they speak down
on the men that allow us to do what we
do right like doing this someone in a
factory had to make this microphone you
know what I mean like we need Factory
workers we need truckers we need
plumbers and I I think that average
women don't respect average men anymore
and I think it is very risky because
what I've seen like just doing the
divorce documentary is the men that get
screwed over the most aren't the rich
men the rich men might pay the most but
they can kind of recover and make make
their money back later do you know what
I mean yeah it's the average man or the
ones like that I've seen like commit
suicide and divorce or um like I would
say on the brink of suicide or ones that
get false accusations or
um worked the same job for 20 years and
then their wife took half like imagine
like the average divorce is 46 years old
so again like my my
um my one point is that a lot of the men
that talk about this they're not over
the average age of first divorce and a
third of them will uh half of them will
divorce if they're Christian it's like a
quarter right and a lot of the men that
commit suicide in this country over this
stuff are the men that worked 20 years
then their wife takes half their [__]
alienates them from their children and
they haven't seen them in many many like
sometimes it's like two three years and
these are the Uber drivers the truck
drivers the plumbers the factory like
these are average men
um and so I think a lot of times like
the tall good looking successful men
will kind of [__] on them but most of
them can't do what they do without them
yeah I mean speak to your point about
plumbers in particular plumbers some
construction workers yeah if you think
about firefighters yeah these are
occupations also because of their
exposure to that environment they may be
getting cancer at a higher rate than a
general population wow I didn't even
think about that yeah so not only is
that plumber maybe more exposed to an
environment and toxins that give them a
higher rate of probability of getting
cancer same with the firefighter you
should see how many of them get cancer
or or or or or or or some of our
veterans right
right so so not only are they not making
a high income they're more exposed to
these chronic conditions
I think they for sure deserve much more
respect at the very least Top Class
Healthcare but that's that's my
a lot of times though
they'll say that they're cry babies or
whatever but it's like no I I don't I
don't think it's these men that can't
get whim this is my experience maybe you
think differently but yeah yeah I don't
see them as these men that can't get
women I see them as average men who
thought they signed up for the wife and
kids and were absolutely devastated when
they had no idea what family court is
like
yeah and and I think until you've really
spent like a week in Family Court to see
no these were not loser men these were
not men that couldn't get it's just it's
the average man that built this country
that are getting absolutely destroyed by
these women and it's not a fringe cases
it's not exceptions like this is common
and I do this on shows all the time I'll
say do you know a guy that's been
falsely accused raise your hand the
whole room raises their hands you know
like like this is a huge risk for men
and I I don't say don't do it I think
you know sometimes you find a woman that
you think is worth the risk and I think
that's beautiful but what I don't think
is good is to encourage young men to be
naive yeah well to Mike's credit he did
say 90 percent
I don't even think it's that high what
do you think I mean okay do you think 60
of men are losers 45 of men are 45
percent of men run the infrastructure of
this country so that means one out of
every two men does a job that helps you
live the way you live so they do the
factory workers they're they're plumbers
they're truckers they build the
buildings Drive the roads and I think
it's like I I don't really like
influencers [__] on the average men
that allow us to do what they do are
they just losers half of the men that
run this country are just whining that
they can't get women you know those men
used to get a wife and a kid that used
to be the standard and like what's
changed I don't think they're losers you
know yeah it's it's like the cringe of
uh you know what's changed just look at
the media look at the movies like I saw
this Jennifer Lawrence supposed to write
here in London yeah right when I get
here I see Jennifer Lawrence poster and
I I like it's like the cringe inside of
me was so intense
there's a Jennifer little Jennifer
Lawrence poster and she's this strong
dominant intelligent woman oh yeah and
then she's next to uh this week no you
know docile idiotic
awkward young man yeah and I'm just
there thinking why are we continuously
making these men we're shaming these men
into Oblivion correct then other women
watch it and think this is this is it
like the band's supposed to be
subservient yeah meanwhile China is
Raising strong man Russia is Raising
strongmen Iran is Raising strong man
we're going to get we're going to we're
this is like the it's like Elon Musk
said like this feels like the Roman
Empire like we're falling apart yeah our
men have become women bro yeah well then
women have become men too and but but in
reality when it's Chinese men against
American women we lose correct there's a
there's a point when reality comes to
everyone's
face yeah we can't hide from reality
forever but that's my point because like
if he's if he's saying that the the men
that are walking away 90 are just losers
well then you're calling 63 of American
men losers really
63 percent
are you so amazing like like it's just I
I just think that's a bit conceited I
think I think you kind of have to hear
where they're coming from and I I don't
I really I you know at first like I kind
of had similar thoughts but then after
interviewing like man after man I've
interviewed men that made six figures
that this happened to yeah I've
interviewed men that like I I just
interviewed a guy who's a Bollywood
actor so he was a he had a modeling
contract he was an actor same thing
happened to him he was just a loser
really and now he hasn't seen his kids
in three years
like imagine what that would do to you
you have daughter how old is she one
imagine if you haven't seen her in three
years because and I'm not I pray this
would never happen to you so don't take
this as like you know but like imagine
what that would do to you as a guy like
you haven't seen the like the person you
love more than anyone in the world for
three years now his daughter or I think
actually it was a son refuses to say his
name because of all the trash the mom
has talked about him he had he had money
right and he was fighting in court and
he he can't see his kid
so is is he just a loser who's saying
there's no and he even said I wanted the
fairy tale ending I thought I found my
happily ever after he says this to me
and this is a guy that's tall Rich good
looking and he's better off than I I
would argue he has a better shot at
recovering than say a factory worker
which is one of the number one like
that's one of the number one p waves
people are employed in America truckers
Factory where Uber drivers are getting
pretty big you know so I mean I mean to
your point
look at what's happening to Russell
Brand and uh right uh innocent Family
Man uh Tristan and Andrew Tate I mean
you basically have women from years ago
who can just literally engage in what
what normal people would call slander
and defamation of character but now
these have become just regular things
you can say to destroy damage smear a
man's entire career and you have
complete immunity from prosecution you
have complete immunity in court you can
just destroy she can't those women can
now just say uh maybe it wasn't true
they walk away but they've already
caused millions of dollars of damage and
my my whole point is until you change
some of these systems yeah it's it's
systematic well men just are going to
keep walking regardless of what because
they always say I'm leading I'm leading
men into destruction regardless of what
I say you're gonna see the same thing
the irony that you would be leading I
know I know well I mean this is like the
1984 like the idea that you would be
doing that when you're suggesting hey
this justice system this is systematic
abuse of fair Justice for men and not
only that Pearl were literally
encouraging incentivizing and
celebrating women to engage in slander
defamation of character and to
financially damage men with no fine no
legal repercussions we're literally
everyone every man like Russell Brand
that goes down or an innocent family man
like Tristan Satan Andrew when they see
that their freedom is taken we are
literally rewarding and encouraging a
million other women to do the same to
someone in their local Town yeah yeah
and that's that's what's horrifying yeah
and that's that's why I don't really
like when this is why I like this is why
I'm glad we could have this conversation
I empathy like I had nine siblings my
parents are still merely people think I
have this like evil I've seen my parents
built a multi-million dollar business
together they had 10 kids like I hope my
daughter talks about me the way you talk
yeah yeah yeah like exactly your dad I
have I have seen the
what I would describe divorce as for
many men is death
and this might sound dramatic but I mean
imagine not seeing your daughter for
years that's death to him imagine a lot
of these men their reality is that
another man is going to have more
influence on their child than them
because twenty percent of divorces they
only see their daughter every other
weekend
the other 20 it's like limited so half
of divorces the man has very little to
no contact with his child
that is he has no control over what men
come into like like that's death to a
man and that and I think that's even
worse than the financial stuff I think
so many guys would give up all their
money just to see their kids and they
and they I meet them and so to act like
okay you know a guy's saying you know
that's just too much of a risk for me
and walking away is like a loser I just
don't buy it I think until you fix the
system we're never gonna have progress
well do you think only fans should be
legal in America
as a woman I I think I would ban it if
it was up to me I I think it should be
illegal because I just think right now
and I'm not saying like obviously
there's going to be women that get away
with it or whatever but
I guess you kind of have to ask your
question in a society
should we ban things that are immoral
and some people would say no people are
going to do it every anyway but I guess
what what formed my opinion was weed
okay now when I was in high school weed
was kind of like
it was like taboo a bit more like I know
like people smoked it whatever but I
just think like there's been a change in
society in America since you can like go
down the street and buy it where
obviously people were gonna smoke it
anyway but I don't really like the idea
of there being a storefront that anyone
can go and just buy the weed we all know
what's gonna happen but at least when
they do it it's like how do I put it
it's more behind closed doors I'm not
even I don't even really care if they go
after them that much I just don't like
living in a world where like it's like
easy to get now weed is one thing but I
think of the idea of like prostitution
do I like the idea of it being like
Amsterdam where it's like even though
men do it anyway in America right
obviously like Vegas whatever I don't
really like the idea of raising my kids
in a world where prostitution is just
like normalized to be out in public yeah
and I would say the same thing with only
fans like obviously they're going to
figure out ways to do it but at least
like let's let's start Banning them
like so they can't publicly talk about
it anymore you know what I mean so they
can't publicly promote it if you figure
out a way to do it against the law fine
I don't care right I'm not saying we
should expend tons of police resources
going after them whatever but at least
guys like I just don't want to be in a
world like where it's so open uh Playboy
settle down once they find a woman they
think is worth settling down for
um okay I think there's two types I
think there's the type of Playboy that
will be single forever like I don't see
Drake ever getting married and now I
know I use Drake as an example I know
he's an exception but I think what you
see in celebrities you also see like the
micro versions of them and like the town
so like the Drake of his they're never
getting married you know I sometimes I I
wonder if do you think Drake is actually
gay like he's just bi Yeah Yeah Yeah by
I think he's probably about yeah I think
he's bi or um I think a lot of guys that
go down the sexual quality route too
hard end up like [__] [__] and
stuff yeah like that just I don't know I
just I I feel like porn kind of leads
men that way and I the same way I think
extreme
um attention ruins women I think extreme
sex kind of ruins men like when at a
young age they get access to like their
wildest sexual fantasies and I think
that kind of some of them get kind of
wacky and I think Drake kind of kind of
it looks like that with the nail polish
and [__] yeah it is feminine for Drake
to have like the nail polish yeah and
what's next is going to wear a wig like
what's next is he gonna wear a skirt
like you know where do we draw the line
now
um and then you wear heels you know
what's interesting okay there's like a
different view on bisexuality of the
Next Generation
um and I I had this I was on a live once
with um my sister this was like a year
and a half ago my sister was in England
and
um they asked me if I would ever date a
guy that was bi and I said oh hell no
like if you kiss the man once over with
you you you and he's like I bet you your
little sister has a different view on it
because she's um my little sister's
seven six six seven years younger than
me
um and I go up to her and I asked her
and my next little sister I'm like oh we
don't care
and it seems to be like a more accepted
thing now like to buy stuff with guys I
don't like it but yeah yeah yeah
it's almost like Drake's making it
popular bad money yeah yeah right but
yeah they're pushing it
um
okay so
um what do you think about Playboys
though do you think um what
what percent of playboys settle down I
think a lot of the Playboys that I know
generally will settle down in their late
30s early 40s okay late 30s early and I
think if they don't meet if they don't
catch that train
they may just be Playboys